smoking in real life be like
I was smoking in manga that's like
you got cancer Slice of Life it's the
genre that hey hey hey hey hey hey
I'm talking here it's the genre I've
never been able to fully get into
because well a lot of the times I find
it boring I can see it's appeal but way
too often it's about shows or stories
that have zero interest or relatability
to cause look I'm a 32 year old
grown-ass adult what the hell am I gonna
have in common with watching the 100th
show about some high school girls
sitting in a classroom going
[Music]
there is rarely anything in this genre
for me so it came as a big surprise when
I found smoking behind the supermarket
with you a manga that tackles something
I can finally relate to something that's
not more cute anime girl something I
rarely get to see being a boring ass
adult this manga might have ignited the
fire in me I had no idea could be
ignited the hitter spot I am now trying
relentlessly to fill up and if you're a
boring ass adult like me I think you
might like it too
oh and there's a whole anime goth girl
in there oh my God and before that let's
talk about the sponsor of today's video
raycon guys as you might know I've been
traveling around a lot recently and
having multiple pair of headphones has
become a necessity I need to pair with
me when I travel when I go to a gym I
need an extra special pair with me when
I'm
doing research thankfully raycon has my
bag with these affordable noise
isolating earbuds they've been on a
mission to prove that people shouldn't
have to pay more than necessary for top
quality especially in this economy you
can buy more than one pair in a variety
of different colors and still pay less
than what you would be compared to other
big name brands without worrying about
quality which is a good thing for me
because I lose and misplace my
headphones all the damn time
that wasn't scripted that's generally
just the truth their everyday earbuds
can last up to 8 hours and their custom
gel tips ensure that things never feel
uncomfortable being water and sweat
resistant also means that I know they're
going to last a long time too and best
of all if you're dissatisfied then
raycon has an easy and free return
policy but with over 50 000 5 Star
reviews and amazing Crystal Clear audio
quality I don't see why you would so
what are you waiting for click that link
in the description or go to buy
raycon.com to get 15 off your raycon
purchase thank you to Recon for
sponsoring me today and with that said
back to the video Sasaki doesn't have a
lot going on in his life working at a
soul-sucking job for a company that
barely treats him like a human being he
doesn't have a lot to look forward to in
his day-to-day grind that is except for
the cheerful smile of Yamada the lovely
clerk at the supermarket he visits after
a shift that brings him just a small
dose of joy in his otherwise tedious
life after one particularly grueling day
however he pops in to find out that
she's already ended a shift so to deal
with the fact that today he doesn't get
to see yamada's joyful face there's only
one one solution he can think of lung
cancer how many cigarettes on
unfortunately in Japan huffing copium in
public has been made illegal and also
slightly frowned upon so looking for a
place to spark up a city in private he
gets called over behind the supermarket
by a mysterious girl who calls herself
tayama wow what a unique name I wonder
where she got that from huh she looks a
little edgy slick leather jacket choker
boots dark lipstick but looks a little
familiar hey I wonder what the old man
thinks I've never met this man in my
life she's noticed that he's always
stopping at yamada's cashier and teases
him a bit yeah she's a little cheeky bit
of a cheeky girl probably eats a lot of
Nando's but finds out that Sasuke
doesn't have any ulterior motives he's
just an older dude who appreciates
yamada's gleeful energy they get talking
and a small friendship starts to form
and so Sasaki finds a new cycle in his
daily routine as every time he visits
the supermarket he shares a smoke break
with this mysterious girl as they talk
about
stuff yeah that's it that's that that's
the manga yes this is a monger about two
adults who go behind the supermarket to
share a smoke break together now before
I recommend this manga as we all know
smoking is bad for your health here are
just some of the negative effects of
smoking increased risk of cancer heart
disease lung disease Strokes chronic
bronchitis emphysema and everyone else
my patreon for helping to support me for
this month and a shitload of other stuff
that is just absolutely terrible for
your health now are there any positive
effects of smoking getting the chance to
Vibe with a hot goth girl behind your
local combini
smoking behind the supermarket with you
was one of the most popular and hyped up
newly published Series in Japan last
year and when I read the first chapter I
didn't understand why five chapters
later I still didn't understand why 26
chapters later and I still didn't
understand why but where the hell is the
next chapter wait this is a monthly
release I have to wait a bloody month
now oh no I like this manga it's
comforting it's relatable it's needs a
shorter name because God damn this is
going to be tedious to pronounced but
most importantly it is a Vibe if you're
over the age of 23 because most
extraordinarily it is a manga starring
actual adults no overly anime [__]
no exaggerated personalities just two
fully grown adults chilling with each
other talking about random [__] it's a
story that perfectly portrays the vibe
of the small intricacies and mundanity
of adult life and I know that sounds
like a weird way to make a story sound
appealing but hear me out okay alright
it's time for a party but stick with me
I swear I'm going somewhere with this
back during the days when I worked for
the United Kingdom transmission
organization I had my little routine
there would be a single Tesco's Express
on my way back and every day I would go
in and give myself a little treat we all
love to clown on British food rightly so
but one thing I'll always happily defend
is their crisps it's pretty much the
only time you'll find properly seasoned
food in England and to me one stood
above them all Walkers Max Punchy
paprika Ridge cut crisps with that
perfect thickness to give it that Crunch
and maximize the delicious Smoky paprika
flavor all for the price of 75p this was
my little tree to signify the end of A
Hard Day's work so you'd understand my
horror when one day I walked in and I
found out that this particular branch of
Tesco's had stopped selling Walkers Max
crisps
why why would they do this what did they
expect me to do settle for the inferior
plain old Walkers crisps settle for a
flavor that's not Punchy paprika add
five minutes on my daily walk home so I
can see if Sainsbury's has it no I
wasn't gonna do that I refused to do
that so like a true Brit I masked my
disappointment by finally complaining to
my mind walking home dejected and crisps
less and returned the next day to burn
the entire store down now that may have
sounded like a weird tangent but that
was a slice of my adult life sometimes
the smallest and most mundane things is
the stuff that stands out the most in
your day and thus the vibe that is
perfectly captured in smokers Anonymous
behind Tesco's Express Sasaki doesn't
come to the same cashier every day
because he has a weird creepy Crush but
because seeing that joyful smile
brightens his day just a little bit
she's no Punchy paprika but I get it and
tayama serves as the emotional Crux I
wish I had when I couldn't tell anybody
about the atrocity Tesco's had committed
on me that day Sasaki finishes work one
day after accidentally making a girl cry
because he tried giving a team member
encouraging words but under
intentionally came off as angry and
aggressive in England we call that
forgetting to end your business emails
with kind regards and instead just
saying regards he tells tayama about it
and she gives him a sound pep talk about
how [__] like this doesn't matter in the
long term if you're a good person that
team member will eventually realize that
in time but if you're really worried
about it here's how the smile and not
look like an angry psychopath he starts
to laugh she gives them a bit of [__]
back he starts to worry that he
accidentally just made her angry then
and there and she's like nah don't
overthink it bro and that's it that's a
chapter there's just something
satisfying about seeing people bonding
and growing closer over the simplest
conversations work life dating small
menial [__] that happens in their day
just two adults being real with each
other and as someone who's introverted
these are the situations I love alright
fellow introverts hear me out talking to
strangers can be scary talking to people
you don't know can be exhausting but to
me it all becomes worth it in that
moment when you find that one person you
just instantly Vibe with it doesn't have
to be about having the same common
interests as them or even having similar
personalities something about that
energy just clicks with you for once you
don't feel like you're draining your
social energy hanging out with someone
one five minute interaction accidentally
turns into a two-hour conversation as
you lost track of time talking about
[__] you don't even remember talking
about and that's the beauty encapsulated
in this manga Sasaki and tayama aren't
necessarily similar they aren't even
that close to each other in age but God
damn if there isn't something comforting
about their chemistry together you're
just watching two adults vibing with
each other shooting the [__] about stuff
that doesn't really matter and I didn't
know I could get this invested in a
story about two people just enjoying
each other's company as time goes on we
even see a slight romance subplot start
to form we might want to keep this on
the download because I do have a bit of
an age Gap and we don't want to give
Twitter something new to pretend to be
mad about I want problems always but
rest assured is treated as maturely as
the rest of the manga is from the start
Sasuke never came in with nefarious
intentions and the evolution of their
relationship feels completely natural as
they slowly start to emotionally rely on
one another give each other companion
ship so any kind of developing feelings
never takes priority over what they
provide for each other and why they keep
coming back an honest to God human
connection all right I would be lying
though if I didn't say I wasn't just a
little bit invested because tayamo is
just perfect the leather jacket the
choker the punk energy adding just a
tiny bit of energy she gets a little
cheeky has a little devious side to her
personality but it's nothing but just a
better banter wait a minute another
manga about a guy in a mischievous anime
girl with a romantic tension wait a
minute this is just another teasing
Margo wait a minute this this is just
nagatora faults the only prophecy right
now is that because this manga is still
pretty new and it's on a monthly release
schedule I've not had nearly enough to
satisfy my craving which caused me to
come to the realization when searching
for similar stories is that why is there
not more shows like this we have an
avalanche of Moe blob high school girls
doing some mundane activity and you know
I get it it's cute it's comfy but whose
Slice of Life is this I like my cute
anime girls but I can't relate to this
what do you think I look like a [__]
Funko Pop there must be some Slice of
Life with adults out there oh hell yeah
new game A Slice of Life about working
adults under the game development what
this this is the adults sparking up a
city next to the Lawsons hits a spot I
didn't know I wanted it to hit and if
that sounds like your thing please dear
God just give it a read because not only
do I want this to get more popular but I
want more stories like this no High
School anime [__] no after school
club activities no cute girls doing cute
things we have adult people doing adult
things wait a minute no cute anime girls
just a bunch of adults talking about
dumb [__] that doesn't really matter
why does this sound so familiar to me
oh [__]
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month too Alpha
Sigma author Curtis Eckstein basil
dysfunctional degenerate flabberwocky
ivido levados misaka one two three one
five Payne Patchett Pony Stark water
Geist VT and everyone else my patreon
for helping to support me for this month
and making this video possible now guys
if you haven't heard already I am going
to be going on tour in Europe yes after
the US taught me and the trash taste
boys are now going to be touring Europe
this year and just before you say
anything we know it's a North Europe
tour sorry South Europeans yes we're
gonna be hitting Dublin Copenhagen
Amsterdam Stockholm Oslo Berlin London
and Cardiff so if you're in any of those
cities at the end of August to
mid-september come check us out links in
the description if tickets are already
on sale and if not well look out for the
announcement anyway though that's it
from me I've been gigguk and I'll see
you all